I'm afford the small business owner but
I also know you know Tyson JB these guys
are gonna come out I'm even her jbs was
trying to buy a national beef back in oh
nine that would have been a whole big
monopoly and Jamie the Brazilian based
company which makes no sense for let's
talk about that Patrick because jbs and
national maar Frigg are both Brazilian
owned jbs is vote owned by the Padilla
Bautista family Jos Lee and Wesley are
the two brothers that are heads of that
preparation and those people those
brothers just got out of prison in
Brazil for fraud and unfair market or
trade practices in their country they
just got out of prison both of those
boys fifty years a year in prison for
fraud they in 2017 jbs if we were
importing Brazilian beef they said not
us they sense it all over the world
rotten meat they got caught in a scandal
it is a food safety issue like no other
and when you have to I mean we're
selling our souls to other countries
we're depending on other countries the
same way with China everybody's talking
this week about all of their medical
supplies coming from China right nobody
knew that I didn't know that I tell you
I I'm on a weekly regimen of
chemotherapy and have been for a year
and a half we don't I don't know where
that comes from I never thought about it
right
so now we have all these people don't
know where their food supply is coming
from and there it's all a safety issue
right I mean when two of our four main
beef packers are Brazilian own foreign
own and they have that much power and
they've been caught in these fraudulent
cases in their own countries what do you
think they're doing the United States
right they don't care about the American
consumer and I'm not against the
American Dream I love this the guy gets
parts out small gets big and grows big I
think it's I think that's awesome
but this isn't that this is this is a
corruption and when people say shed what
would you do to change the industry I
start at the top and I say we got to end
corrupt
we have to we have enforces the Packers
and stockyards act of 1921
which guaranteed a level playing field
for the producer cleared of the pattern
we have to enforce antitrust laws that
we have on the books that keep these
acquisitions and murders from happening
we have these laws why aren't they being
implemented why is the federal
government allowing the acquisitions and
mergers to gain control because it's a
part of a globalist economy a global
economy and I'm fine with the global
economy but it's got to be fair for the
producer it's got to be parrot fair for
the independent producer of the United
States any producers whether you're
pretty missing rocky chairs or counts
right the American Dream is about
private property rights without your
ability to own private property rights
or to own private property whether its
land or a business in town you don't
have the ability to be a part of a free
market system capitalistic system and
these are all private property rights
that are being taken away from us day by
day how Howard how well let's let's
let's take for example there's in
production agriculture there's these new
measures called the global roundtables
and let's take the specific one that I
know deeply about is called the global
roundtable for sustainable B and what
that is is that is was created by the
United Nations it they implemented this
control mechanism called the global
roundtable for sustainable beef they
implemented it across the world through
the World Wildlife Fund the World
Wildlife Fund is a environmental
organization that does not believe in
private property rights they're they're
very enormous lis money driven
organization that wants to take you off
off your land so they have implemented
this deal called the global round table
for sustainable beef and it controls
production standards from top to bottom
so what it does is they they come in at
the top of the chain the supply chain
and they say okay you're gonna produce
this this this at this cost you're going
to implement
these production standards you're going
to do this to your cattle you're gonna
do this to your land they're gonna have
third parties that come in and audit it
and then and then and so then they have
you captured and it creates bottleneck
and if you don't get on board you you
are not allowed to play in the market
and that has already come to fruition in
Brazil under the global roundtable for
sustainable soy in 2016 they implemented
that and a whole host and I won't say
how many of those Brazilian soybean
farmers declined to be a part of the
global roundtables for sustainable soy
they were kicked out of the market and
many of them committed suicide these are
control communistic methods that have
you embrace you by the neck they take
you by the neck and you are going to
adhere to their production standards
from top to bottom or you're not going
to be in the system
[Music]